hey there guys thanks joonyoung so today
i want to talk to you about what is now
my favorite new piece of training
equipment and that is parallel bars
these are very affordable I think I paid
30 to 40 quid for them which is about
$60 probably the pound is crashing so
I'm not sure exactly and they're just as
versatile as a put bar if not more so
they're awesome for all kinds of basic
exercises and for learning some pretty
cool moves as well so I'm going to show
you some of my favorite exercises with
them and hopefully by the end of this
video you will be convinced to pick up a
pair yourself
okay so here they are parallel bars
they're pretty easy to understand their
bars and you stand them opposite each
other thus making them parallel they're
very easy to stack if you stand like so
they don't take up much space at all see
just put them somewhere in your room you
can slide them under a bed they're very
easy to build you just basically get
these two bits and you attach them here
he wants it from men's health but I've
seen plenty better models
the most obvious thing you can do with
these is dips so you just hold on to the
handles there and lower yourself and the
great thing about dips with parallel
bars like these is that you committed
bars further apart or you can make them
narrower you can even having them kind
of like this make it more of a tricep
exercise we've got rocking dips I like
the easy dip down more on one side and
then the other side in order to isolate
and focus on that side of the body
extended extended range abrasion
push-ups and of course any exercise
where you're pointing downwards more
will train your shoulders more like
putting your legs higher up and pointing
your body down with slightly and like I
said this is a full body workout - or at
least a full upper body workout - and
there's plenty you can do to your biceps
- if you sit down here underneath grab
the handles you can do neutral grip
pull-ups and if you lean your body back
then you'll be able to extend your arms
the whole way and go
for the upside down if you so wish all
right
likewise you can opt to use just the one
side in performing pull-ups like say
again I'm rocking back to make my arms
able to extend all the way which also
places the emphasis nicely on the biceps
of course you can do press over hand and
underhand the grip as well I'm one of my
favorite exercises is inverted push-up
which is a pull-up where you keep your
heels on the ground and you pull
yourself up like say you've got shrugs
not your regular strokes complete weight
is coming from the other direction but
it's an exercise this gymnastics team
you've got your elf sit and your VSIP
you've got plenty of leg raise type
exercises I like to do make you learn
that raises and again once I can't do
anymore I begin to be Rock cakes which
are different in your knees variations
on that yeah plenty
you've just got your other variations on
dips
of course you can do one bar or a tricep
dip if you have a you know bench or
something that you can put your legs on
opposite but to get the very most out of
these why I recommend what I always
recommend a very exercise is that you
use the kind called drop set well I
always recommend process so no caliper
drop set means you do move that you find
very hard and perhaps you may do a few
are and then you move straight is
something you find easier that's
allowing yourself to go past failure so
in this case we might do with many tips
as we can do then we might be extended
range of motion push-ups
on something and then we might go
straight into regular push-ups and this
allows us to keep on going even when our
muscles are fatigued and that's how you
stimulate growth creating micro tears
and build strength and this is great for
doing that for dropping down different
movements likewise you could do some
curls some pull-ups from the bars and
you could pull ups and then you can go
straight into inverted push-ups and that
way again you've dropped down and
managed to keep going past failure give
that a try because that's what really
creates a massive amount of burn I'm
also a huge fan of doing mechanical
process within a single exercise and the
way I like to do this is in this
instance I would do as many dips as I
could dig and then say I'm sorry to fail
what I do is touch my feet lightly to
the ground and begin to put some of the
weight onto my legs
gradually as I fatigue more and more I
start doing more and more of it with my
legs so it's like having an assistant in
the gym having a partner to spot you and
gradually help you
my legs are gradually becoming more
involved in the movement of my arms and
my pecs are fatiguing and so I can
really squeeze out every last bit of
effort until the point where I'm unable
to use my arms at all again the kind of
burn you'll feel when you do that you'll
notice working it give it a game the
reason I got them is to learn some cool
moves and I find this very exciting for
doing things like handstands learning
plans etc see what I can do shall we
need to look up need to hold it longer
but I'm getting there and of course you
can use it for handstands yeah depending
on the height of your ceiling and
possibly book spare change
there's lots of but that progressions
you can use to get up to that point
because most people either you can't do
a handstand press up or you can't do it
well enough like me to make it into a
useful exercise you can do on a daily
basis but there's loads of steps that
you can get to you before you get there
which a lot of people will be able to
use and then they'll not only build up a
lot more strength but they'll also be
able to develop those moves eventually
so an example of this is tuck planche
tuck planche is punch but where your
body is in a tuck position and you could
move down hands then press up esque move
you know somewhere between planets and
press up and what I like to do is just
to block the body this uses lots of I
believe from this position to that one I
think that's a great then exercise you
can use you just build up to the point
where you can do that sort of thing not
blown away yet
then what about using them as hurdles
let's just say how much you can do with
parallel bars I've exhausted just from
filming this video how many men do the
work out there fun evenings about cool
moves of them and if you use them as
part of a drop set and especially if you
combine with other exercises then they
can give you a real brutal full-body or
full upper body workout so I highly
recommend these as a purchase and in
fact I'd say they're as useful or more
useful than a pull-up bar and there's
something I'd recommend that anyone at
any level add to their collection so
hopefully this video has convinced you
that this is a worthwhile purchase and
of course you don't get these you can do
a lot of the moves I've just shown you
by pushing two chairs together or even
inside your back but yeah that's a pain
I made that difference a
long time ago by hollowing out the
inside of a chair but I just wanted you
to consider some form of dipping setup
for your home workout I hope you found
this video interesting and useful if so
please consider how I can change
subscribing down the bottom and I'll
catch you for the next one where I'll
probably be talking about more fitness
or perhaps psychology or nootropics or
technology because that's what I do here
at the bilayer thanks a lot for watching
and bye for now